henry morgan's daring borderline
reckless raids became the stuff of
legend and he successfully plundered
more than his fair share of booty in the
west indies and best of all he got away
with it henry morgan did not die in
battle and did not end up on the end of
a noose few other captains from his time
had that privilege and none of them did
it quite like morgan who after his
plundering days were done became a
nobleman and a politician reveling in
the admiration and respect of his peers
so was he a pirate or was he a privateer
the answer really depends on who you ask
but there is no denying that henry
morgan has earned his spot as one of the
most notorious men to sail the seven
seas
henry morgan's early life is very
obscure although most sources indicate
that he was born circa 1635 in the welsh
town of lien romney which today is a sub
of cardiff we know little else about his
upbringing although a contemporary of
the pirate named alexandre x milor
claimed that morgan came from a wealthy
farming family but that he had no
interest in that life which is why he
became a sailor equivalent will serve as
one of our main sources for the life of
henry morgan he's quite distinctive in
that regard not only was he a
contemporary of the welsh pirates but he
actually served on morgan's ship and was
an eyewitness to many of his exploits
you'd think that that would make him one
of the most credible sources we've ever
had on biographics but he was actually
sued for libel by henry morgan who
claimed that he made up or exaggerated
certain stories in his book history of
the buccaneers of america in order to
make morgan appear more murderous and
cruel well if we're being technical
morgan actually sued the publisher of
the english translation of the book but
the point is that he won however the
matter was settled out of court so
whether or not x-com allah's statements
were true was never established with
certainty we're going to assume that
most of what ex-cubanol said about henry
morgan was true even if he did embellish
certain parts in this case morgan left
his old life behind sometime during the
mid-1650s and traveled to an english
port city from where he boarded a ship
to barbados in the west indies when he
arrived there he was sold as an
indentured servant for a period of three
years this is just one version of events
another claimed that morgan simply
joined a british navy ship to fight in
the anglo-spanish war either way he made
his way to the west indies where the
better known chapter of his life began
in 1655 the english tried to take the
island of hispaniola from the spanish
they failed but they did manage to take
jamaica with an assist from the
buccaneers we should mention at this
point that although nowadays we use
terms like pirate privateer and
buccaneer interchangeably back then they
did mean slightly different things and
it's worth knowing the difference since
henry morgan served as all three at
various times we're all familiar with
pirates they had no loyalty to any
government or king they operated outside
of the law and attacked whoever struck
their fancy privateers on the other hand
were basically state licensed pirates
they received something called a letter
of mark from the admiralty or a governor
and this allowed them to raid certain
ships which usually belonged to another
nation that they were currently at war
with the privateer captain had to secure
his ship and crew out of his own pocket
and he had to send a share of the spoils
to his government but he was not
breaking the law and he had no fear of
legal reprisals in fact some of
history's most successful privateers
such as francis drake someone we've
already covered here on biographics you
can check out the video if you haven't
seen it were regarded as heroes back
home finally we have buccaneers who were
actually a very specific subgroup of
sailors who appeared in the caribbean
sea during the early 17th century they
consisted of a lot of seamen who were
forced to flee the pirate haven of
tortuga when the spanish took control of
it in 1635. also included were social
outcasts such as shipwreck survivors
mutineers and escaped slaves as well as
native americans who settled in parts of
the west indies that the spanish didn't
bother to colonize when other european
nations such as england france or the
netherlands sailed in the caribbean they
found most spanish ports closed to them
and that these people were the only ones
willing to trade the english started
calling them buccaneers from the french
word buccaneer itself derived from
bukhar which is a wooden grill used to
smoke meat and make a jerky that they
often used for trade it wasn't until the
late 17th century that the buccaneers
became powerful enough that they earned
the ire of other nations during the
1650s and 1660s however england was more
than happy to trade with buccaneers and
allow them to use its port since they
represented a cheap way of waging war
with spain
[Music]
once henry morgan was settled in the
west indies around the mid-1650s he
began his career as a privateer although
the exact details are a bit uncertain
it's generally believed that he sailed
under christopher mungs an english naval
officer who assembled a large fleet of
buccaneers and raided spanish merchant
ships excumiore mentions that morgan and
his comrades took part in three or four
such voyages before they raised enough
money to buy their own ship around 1660
henry morgan who was still in his
mid-20s was made captain of his first
vessel he proved to be a very good one
too as he went marauding off the coast
of campeche in the gulf of mexico and
captured several prizes there his
success brought him to the attention of
edward mansfeld a dutch buccaneer who
was one of the head honchos in the area
and he was impressed with morgan's skill
so he asked the young captain to join
his fleet even making him a vice admiral
at the height of his power mansfield
allegedly commanded 15 ships with 500
men in 1664 he used this force to
capture an island named santa catalina
from spain it's not very big but it had
an easily fortified harbor and the
spanish had already built a fort there
mansfeld intended to use it as a base of
operations as he waged war against spain
but he did not get a chance as he died
in 1666 supposedly of a sudden illness
the spanish then retook santa catalina
and many buccaneers went their own ways
without mansfeld's leadership even so
hundreds of others still remained and
sailed under henry morgan the second in
command who was now in charge of his own
fleet his actions at the time were in
illegal gray areas since technically the
war between england and spain had ended
in 1660 when the house of stewart was
restored to the monarchy and charles ii
became the new king of england scotland
and ireland even so hostilities between
the two maritime powers continued in the
caribbean enabled by the fact that
privateers and buccaneers could act
without much oversight from the english
crown henry was also helped by the fact
that his uncle edward morgan served as
the deputy governor of jamaica and by
the fact that the governor thomas
martiford already tried to curtail the
activity of privateers but almost
immediately had to reverse course
because his island's economy just
depended on them too much of course
spain wasn't just gonna sit idly by and
allow its ships to be constantly raided
without retaliation by 1667 governor
marty ford had strong reasons to fear
that the spanish might invade jamaica so
he decided that a pre-emptive strike
would be in order he presented henry
morgan with a letter of mark against
spain thus allowing him to attack in
full force even though they were not at
war at the time almost immediately
morgan exceeded his authority by raiding
the town of puerto principa in cuba
today known as camogue his letter of
mark only allowed him to attack spanish
ships but towns made for very alluring
targets since they were often easier to
plunder especially if caught off guard
this is the main reason why some
scholars have dismissed the notion that
henry morgan was a privateer and simply
label him a pirate since he often acted
outside of his remit initially the
captain wanted to attack havana
believing that a surprise attack would
allow them to arrive in the city plunder
it and leave before the spanish had time
to reach their positions inside the fort
however he was dissuaded from this
course of action on the ground that
havana was too heavily fortified and
even a large fleet such as his would
sustain heavy casualties instead morgan
settled on puerto principe as an excuse
for his actions he sent word to the
governor that he found evidence of an
invasion against jamaica being organized
there in reality at least according to
ectomy there was a man in morgan's crew
who suggested puerto principe claiming
that there was money there since
savannah merchants did a lot of business
in that town and because it was some
distance inland so there was no fear of
raiders so it wasn't heavily defended
even though it made for an easy target
the raid on puerto principe didn't go
very well first off there was a spanish
prisoner aboard morgan's ship who
learned of their plan he managed to
escape during the night and reached
puerto principe in time to warn the
locals who then sent most of their
riches away and then chopped down trees
and set up small ambushes on the road to
slow down the raiding party inevitably
though the fighting started at which
point the spanish villagers proved to be
no match for the battle hardened
buccaneers the skirmishes lasted for
about four hours ending in a decisive
victory for morgan's crew who suffered
only a few casualties afterwards the
locals were locked up in the churches
while the pirates plundered their town
at this point according to exumior
morgan starved and tortured the
townsfolk in order to get them to
surrender their riches eventually he
agreed to allow a few of them to leave
the town and travel to another city to
secure a ransom for the release of his
prisoners but he soon discovered that he
had been deceived instead of getting the
money the town's people were delaying
him as long as possible as the governor
of santiago was sending an army to
puerto principe left no other choice
morgan carried what little plunder he
had aboard his ships and departed the
town before the reinforcements arrived
and if that was not bad enough he also
had to contend with a possible riot
following an argument between an english
and a french privateer which resulted in
the englishman killing the frenchman to
show that he did not play favorites
morgan had the english sailor chained up
and delivered him to stand trial in
jamaica where he was hanged even so the
french were still unhappy sailing under
henry morgan's command and most of them
around 200 men in all left his fleet
soon after and went back to tortuga
the less than stellar attack on puerto
principe did not diminish morgan's
ambitions and he chose as his next
target the town of portobello located in
modern-day panama this was a high-risk
reward situation as the settlement was
heavily fortified but also sat on the
principal trading route between the
spanish maine and spain meaning that it
always had valuable cargo import in july
1668 morgan anchored his ships near
portobello again he preferred a stealthy
approach and this time there was nobody
to spoil his surprise attack his men
boarded a few dozen canoes and paddled
at night in silence reaching portobello
and starting their raid before dawn they
caught the locals unaware and even
though the town had three castles few
spanish soldiers actually had time to
reach their fortified positions
allegedly morgan devised a particularly
cruel strategy to protect his men during
their assault on the last castle by
using spanish priests and nuns as human
shields this is all according to ex
camillon who claimed that morgan
gathered the religious men and women of
portobello and had them place ladders on
the walls of the castle and then climbed
them ahead of his companies so that the
enemy would not open fire something
which they did anyway this was the part
in excamino's book that henry morgan
objected to and later successfully sued
for libel he got it removed from the
english translations of the book but
since the matter was settled out of
court we still don't know for sure if
morgan actually ever used nuns as human
shields either way his raid on
portobello was a big success he not only
plundered the town for many riches but
held it for ransom afterwards the
spanish made an attempt to retake
portobello by force but the pirates
repelled the attack and then the local
governor had no choice but to pay the
ransom of a hundred thousand pesos or
have the entire town reduced to ashes
everyone on morgan's crew left
portobello a rich man receiving a share
worth several times their annual wages
of course as captain henry morgan
received a larger share as did governor
moddy ford for issuing the letter of
mark there were some legal ramifications
since as we previously mentioned england
and spain were not at war at the time
ultimately though both morgan and the
governor got off with slaps on the wrist
since realistically everyone back in
england still considered spain to be
their enemy and realized that a new war
was just never too far away in the
months that followed morgan was already
preparing for his next raid but he had a
very close call when one of his ships
exploded with him on board in 1668 he
received some heavy reinforcements in
the form of hms oxford or warship that
governor moriford obtained from the
royal navy to help defend jamaica the
governor added its morgan's fleet who
then promptly made it his new flagship
however he did not get to enjoy it for
long because in january 1669 an errant
spark from a pig roast went into the
oxford's powder magazine blowing up the
ship morgan was one of the lucky ones
because he was situated at the far end
of the ship he was in his cabin eating
and drinking with the captains of his
fleet the explosion simply propelled him
out of the window and onto the water but
350 of his men were not so fortunate and
perished in the blast
[Music]
clearly with almost half his crew dead
morgan needed to reassess the situation
initially he wanted to attack cartagena
to india's one of the biggest port
cities on the spanish main located today
in colombia but now that was off the
table instead he decided to repeat the
rating route that french pirate francois
olyny did two years earlier in lake
maracaibo a tidal bay in modern-day
venezuela this involved two main targets
the city of maracaibo itself and the
town of gibraltar not to be confused
with gibraltar in the iberian peninsula
first came maracaibo which did not prove
to be difficult since it had been mostly
abandoned the privateers spent a few
weeks in the city time during which they
took everything of value that was left
behind they also scoured the nearby
jungles knowing that some of the locals
would not have traveled very far they
were then brought back to maracaibo
where they were tortured to reveal the
locations where they hid their valuables
afterwards morgan sailed across lake
maracaibo to gibraltar where he
encountered heavier resistance but
nothing that posed a serious threat he
spent a few more weeks there but when he
wanted to leave he discovered that he
had been trapped three spanish warships
under the command of don alonso del
campo espanosa waited for him at the
mouth of the lake there was no getting
around them without a fight but what
morgan did next cemented his place in
nautical history the spanish captain
actually sent him a letter offering him
clemency provided that he give up all of
his plunder and prisoners morgan brought
this option to his men who immediately
turned it down preferring to fight and
die then give up their booty but morgan
had a better idea using subterfuge to
defeat his enemy he sacrificed one of
his vessels and turned it into a fire
ship a ship stuffed with explosives that
was deliberately steered into the enemy
formation and abandoned by its crew he
also filled the deck of the ship with
giant wooden logs which were dressed in
coats and hats to disguise them as a
regular crew the plan worked on april
30th 1669 the pirates launched their
attack the spanish did not spot the
deception until it was too late and the
fire ship plowed straight into
espinosa's flagship the magdalena which
was destroyed but that was not the end
as one of the remaining two warships was
run aground in the chaos while the other
one was taken over by the buccaneers and
added to morgan's fleet and so henry
morgan sailed out of lake maracaibo and
into legend as one of the most daring
pirates in history
understandably the spanish were none too
pleased with morgan's actions so under
orders from queen regent maria anna
their privateers wrapped up their raids
on english merchant ships in the region
in response modefoot commissioned morgan
to commit his most ambitious attack yet
an assault on the city of panama one of
the main settlements on the spanish
mainland this was a multi-part plan
since panama wasn't the kind of place
they could just stroll into first morgan
re took the island of santa catalina
from the spanish he used it as a
headquarters where he gathered men and
supplies and discussed the details of
his scheme with his captains estimates
of the size of his army are all over the
place but most agree that it was around
1 800 to 2 000 men from santa catalina
the pirates left for panama approaching
by sailing up the shangra river this
also meant capturing fort san lorenzo
which overlooked the mouth of the river
since morgan did not want to be trapped
again when it was time to leave this was
easier said than done there was the fort
at a garrison of over 300 men and 20
cannons morgan lost around 100 men in
the fight and 17 more were wounded but
the tide turned in his favor when a
musket shot caused the powder magazine
to blow up once the port was under his
command morgan left around 500 men
behind and took the remaining 1 200
through the panamanian jungle in january
1671. this trek lasted for nine days the
spanish knew of their impending arrival
and had employed scorched earth tactics
burning down the villages and the crops
that stood between the pirates in panama
when the buccaneers arrived within sight
of the city they were hungry tired and
demoralized on top of this the spanish
greatly outnumbered them and they had
two squadrons of cavalry they were
expecting an easy victory against a
ragtag band of pirates led by the son of
a welsh farmer but they got exactly the
opposite the cavalry was taken care of
when morgan fained a retreat by sending
part of his army to one flank tricking
the horsemen into pursuing them straight
into the line of fire of his remaining
forces once the cavalry was out of the
way the buccaneers charged into the city
which had almost no fortification so the
fighting was done in the open the
spanish infantry although greater in
number proved no match for the pirates
and it mainly consisted of locals and
slaves none of whom were experienced in
battle morgan had taken panama which was
pillaged and burned to the ground over
the following weeks it was never rebuilt
and today the ruins of old panama are a
unesco world heritage site while the
current panama city was built a few
miles to the west but whether or not
henry morgan was actually responsible
for its obliteration is still a matter
of debate as some sources claimed that
it was the spanish general who ordered
its destruction as he would rather see
it burn and fall into enemy hands the
mission had been a success but the
spoils were surprisingly meager mainly
this was because the plunder had to be
shared among so many men but excavator
did accuse morgan of sneaking the lion's
share of the riches onto his ship either
way when the welsh captain arrived in
jamaica he expected a hero's welcome but
what he got instead was an international
incident in july of 1670 england and
spain had signed the treaty of madrid
specifically intended to finally settle
their disputes in america spain agreed
to recognize jamaica as belonging to
england and in return england had to end
all private curing against spanish ships
the fact that morgan burned to the
ground one of the biggest cities on the
spanish mains so soon after the treaty
was signed what we would today call a
diplomatic faux pas both morgan and
governor modified were arrested and sent
to london to stand trial in an attempt
to appease spain henry morgan would have
been in serious trouble if he was
convicted of piracy fortunately for him
public opinion was firmly on his side as
many considered him a hero and a skilled
military commander he also had a pretty
solid defense arguing that he did not
know about the treaty when he set off
for panama whether or not this was true
well who knows but it was good enough to
get him off the hook in fact king
charles ii even knighted him making him
a baronet in 1674 and appointing him the
new lieutenant governor of jamaica the
now sir henry morgan returned to his old
stomping grounds in jamaica where he
spent the rest of his life involved in
local politics and the defense of the
colony he became a rich man who owned
several plantations and had over a
hundred slaves he also became a heavy
drinker particularly fond of the local
rum which he enjoyed while swapping old
war stories with other former privateers
and buccaneers he died august 25 1688
age 53 possibly due to tuberculosis or
possibly due to his drinking just four
years later a giant earthquake and
tsunami hit port royal jamaica causing
part of the city to slip into the water
quite fittingly this included henry
morgan's grave which became lost at sea
forever so i really hope you found that
video interesting if you did please do
hit that thumbs up button below don't
forget to subscribe and as always
thank you for watching
[Music]